two
welcome
everybody to off the rails i am your
host ethan klein presenting
we are now committed
to off the rails brand so much so
that we even have our own theme song now
here it comes
you guys may uh know otis mcdonald he
makes like all the most jamming
music on youtube that's in like the
library music library
and we commissioned our boy
to make us a song
[Music]
rewind time
we got a whole orchestra 50 pieces
listen to each one
[Music]
they're singers
saxophones
it's a whole
quartet
now i just did it on a keyboard
but um
i love it
here let's break it down a little bit
break it down
otis mcdonald
break it down
peel it out
wait for the drop
i thought i got i thought the drop was a
little more intense
but uh the great otis mcdonald thank you
for the theme song so now we're off the
rails with and it's official
should we call this off the rails number
one
it's really not number one though how do
you numerize it
we can't we can't disrupt the numbering
sequence
okay you know what i mean we've so we've
won so far rails do we put it in the
title are we just off the rails we've
been off the road i think if you know
you know like yeah exactly where this is
off the rails because we're off the
rails self-evident we need like a train
off the rails i think cars aren't
generally on rails
right
today um
i'm so sick of these
dealing with idiots bro i i don't know i
feel like this show is just
from one idiot to another
just [ __ ] shouting at morons like
i'm getting
you know
joe rogan we talked about joe rogan
wasn't it last episode
and like last or the one prior i forgot
joe rogan is on a show telling people
not to get vaccinated you know
carl tucker
carl tucks his dick between his legs
carl tuckerson is the [ __ ] most
despicable person alive as far as i'm
aware right now
and the [ __ ] he says on his show
i can't belie i just i can't believe
what he's saying to be quite frank we're
gonna watch all this stuff
i mean just to give you a taste he i
believe he he was saying
people who wear masks are so offensive
to him he's encouraging now his viewers
to approach people who are wearing masks
and tell them that it's making them
uncomfortable and he said if you see
kids wearing masks you need to call
child protective services or the police
to come
because they are not responsible right
like i mean i'm not off base this is
what he's saying uh yes sir call the
police immediately there you go that's
what he says if you see someone wearing
a mask a kid your mask is making me
uncomfortable right that's the new
i i don't know what to say because like
they're so inconsistent i mean they're
the party of personal freedoms
and now they're not even okay with
people minding their own business and
wearing a mask
right
like i just
his personal his personal like
philosophy there's no coherency in it at
all
none
you know
so there's that you know
there's all kinds of stuff caitlyn
jenner is running for governor god help
us
um but it's not all politics although
let's be frank i mean look
we also have a um powerpoint on this
prank channel that i missed
during my heydays of making fun of
pranks
called luxury pranks which is apparently
one of these legendary prank channels
but
they're new to me
and so that should be fun going over
some of their content
but um
right at the top here we've got a
japanese man
was arrested
after dating more than 35 women at once
for the purpose of getting
birthday gifts
that's [ __ ] that's i mean hey dude if
you can
what a king do you get really i don't
really get that good of birthday
presents yeah justified that much work
look at this is the guy by the way
what would you buy him for his birthday
what whatever he wants whatever he
desires
so apparently this guy was such a
prolific dater
that there was a uh
a support group
formed
right for his exes for his exes
who then reported it to the police
they formed a victims association and
then went to the police
and he was actually arrested
for fraud suspicions of fraud damn
now i don't know how i don't not i don't
know how that's a crime necessarily the
guy's just got game
he's a criminal yeah right he's a
criminal uh player i guess i don't know
the details but i just thought it was a
funny ass headline
i mean i guess if you are
um
you know being given gifts under false
pretense
you know it's not like
i don't know if he's like yo you have to
buy me this
fraud
yeah i don't know that's a weird one i
mean obviously it's [ __ ] up like i
mean it's just basically yeah i'm not
going to pretend to know what the laws
are in japan he's cheating
three dozen people at moments
perfectly fine with that
i would call that a false advertising
right i think jaw real nailed that one
on the head
yeah i don't know in america if this
would be because it's like
if i have
three girlfriend or let's say i have 30
girlfriends
and they all think
they're the only ones how does this guy
have that much time
yeah
that's a full-time job dude they better
be hooking up birthday presents like
like
like a thousand dollars
right that's a good point how does he
make a living
he's preoccupied with dating 35 people
but hey this guy's got swag he's got 35
girlfriends so if you're out there
yeah who who are we to judge you know
he's in sales if that wasn't clear he's
in sales okay
he has a job too
yeah
[Music]
[ __ ] this guy works this guy
works 48
hours a day
where does he find the time for this is
there details about what kind of gifts
he was getting and stuff like that yeah
he says he uh he received gift cards and
presents totaling a hundred thousand yen
which is
uh this article is from britain so it
gives it in pounds but it's only 668
pounds that's come on
this dude's hustling for 600 pounds
he would have made way more money just
working for minimum wage probably
yeah i mean so
you know
the the women
who were victimized by him uh say that
they were scammed which is why you know
he's being charged with fraud
but that's just that's such a gray area
i mean birthday gifts
well i don't know scammed out of a
birthday yeah i'm not sure about it but
hey
first of all what he's doing is wrong
you shouldn't be dating multiple people
like that but
right
i love there's like a sting operation
too with a hidden cam
you know what the real justice would be
someone catfishing him and getting a
birthday present
you know worth like
50 bucks or something 50 bucks got him
weird story alert
apparently he's going to be spending
life in prison for that life in prison
without parole
that i made up
not true
how are you guys doing how's everybody
doing
doing okay
we're doing well we're feeling strong is
everybody um
vaccinated fully vaxxed out now i am
getting my second tomorrow
oh congrats the big day
so i might be really [ __ ] up for uh
after dark on friday potentially yeah
don't worry about that i that's all
right you know i got my second vaccine
on i think last friday
and um
i was i kind of knocked you on your ass
right i was kind of [ __ ] on saturday
but it was just one day and then sunday
i felt great and now i'm fully
vaccinated i feel like a [ __ ]
superhero i'm going to i'm going to go
lick some damn uh door knobs
you know
my uh vaccination process got messed up
because i had the covid scare which i
tested negative thank god
but um
it happened on the day you were supposed
to go get vaccines it was it was the
next day i see
so it's a catch-22
you need the vaccine not to catch the
covid but you've been exposed to covid
from somebody that's been vaccine
make it make sense
oh right i forgot that it was somebody
you know they were fully vaccinated and
they still caught it they were fully are
they okay
yeah they're fine i mean they had
symptoms and [ __ ] um
but i mean it's a [ __ ] miracle that
we tested negative
so um
one shot
one shot they say is actually pretty
effective
the second shot knocks it out of the
park
yeah so i'm going um
next
week
ian are you fully vaxxed
uh yeah two weeks
as of yesterday and you had kelvin too
so you're like the uh
you are the covid warrior champion
dominator
not quite
and my taste never came back fully i
feel like wow damn
are you having any other lasting
symptoms other than taste
i i i don't know i want to go to the
doctor soon i feel like i've been having
some trouble breathing i don't know if
it's related
but
i find myself pretty often especially at
night having to kind of go like
like trying to get a big full breath you
know like if i don't it
you feel like you're not getting enough
oxygen that's terrifying is that a
corpse breath that i just heard
i was snuck in there okay oh my god no
wonder i just came in my pants
i didn't know what happened but i just
got an immediate boner true yeah
yeah i don't know i don't know if it's
covered related or not but i'm gonna go
check that is scary though well it
sounds like it would be i mean if you're
having lung issues and breathing issues
that's all coveted stuff
yeah
oh boy i'm sorry warrior
so you are out there on the front line
man
i don't know what i'm doing
oh okay
i didn't i mean that's fine we're hey
we're all just kind of stumbling through
life right ian
i'm stroking [ __ ] down here
okay i didn't ask about that
i was trying to be inspirational
abe you're fully vaxxed you and lena i
am yes
feels good man it feels really good to
be fully vaccinated i'm thinking we're
even gonna take the family like
disneyland soon because theodore's gonna
be turning two up here pretty soon in
june
and uh
you know he's been locked down for a
whole year so like he has not
he's been so starved for
i'm not starved there's always people
around him but like he's never spent
time with kids
we haven't really been going out in
public and doing fun stuff so now
we're finally able to kind of go out
into the world
and um
it's really exciting it's fun last week
or two weeks ago we went to an aquarium
with theodore
right you know
it's nice it's just [ __ ] it's nice
dude
what is carl gonna what does carl tuck
the penis between the legs gonna do if
he goes to like a public setting
because like at the aquarium and at
disneyland
you have to everybody has to wear their
mask it's like their policy so is tucker
carlson is gonna go there and have a
meltdown uh eyes take off your mask i
mean i don't know for sure but my read
on uh on mr tucker i find him to be
purely cynical i think uh he
i know he hasn't said on his show but i
i'm pretty certain he's fully vaccinated
and will likely wear a mask anywhere he
goes because um he doesn't want to catch
covid but he will say whatever he needs
to say uh on his show that contradicts
that we should watch it because
we keep talking about it
call the police immediately this clip is
the most unhinged disturbing thing
and just remember this is the most
popular
network news channel fox news
and he he has become the most popular
like uh
show is that right no uh yeah he's the
highest rated on fox and like you said
it fox's the highest rate is uh
quote-unquote unquote news channels i
don't know what their end game is i
really don't i mean
i'll be honest like back in i feel like
back in the day when i was doing youtube
i kind of
i understand what it means to get lost
in the sauce a little bit
like
you can get addicted to covering
i'm gonna i'm gonna do a little
self-reflection here as i try to
understand tuck the dick
and back in the day and like uh
i don't know five years ago it was
really popular to be making anti-social
justice warrior videos and when it
started
it was really
i felt just because
it wasn't like a political thing these
people were like back in the day they
were super obnoxious
uh like zarna you know the girl who went
off on humongous for me that was just a
slam dunk she was just so annoying and
like so wrong right
but so over the years though
you start to see that you're getting
this audience you're you're gathering
these audience of reactionaries and you
see like you start to see comments like
making generalizations about all women
and liberals and [ __ ] like that and you
go and then you start seeing your videos
retweeted by people like that i go oh
you know i'm i'm i don't like that guy
you start to see it being retweeted by
people like mark dice you know that guy
i know the name whoever shapiro follows
me
and then like dave rubin follows me and
they all want to get me on the show and
talk about social justice squares and i
was like what is happening you know what
i mean
but the also they get the most views
people love the social justice warrior
thing so it came to a point where i was
like
you get addicted to making that content
because it gets such a
a strong response but part of you is
like
am i do i even believe what i'm saying
now and
and also what is the effect of me making
these videos and the people that are
coming to my channel and watching it
like these you know what i mean so
there's a little bit of a self
delusion that takes place to keep making
those videos it came to the point where
i was like you know i i don't i can't do
this anymore and i think there was a lot
of disenfranchised fans at the time that
were like
when i came out as like a liberal i came
out of the closet as a liberal
are you crazy i felt like i was always
upfront with my politics but people
always like with internet personalities
people always want to pretend like oh
he's one of us
and i most definitely was not one of
them so it was a little disturbing to me
to be like hmm definitely not one of
them but
i can't stop making these videos because
they're just like
get the best response and my channel's
growing you know what i mean
well anyway um that's where i that's
where i the only way i can possibly
identify with what carl tuck the dick is
doing
is that he's lost in the sauce yeah i
think he's ruthless
and uh you know addicted to growing a
show in the ratings you know
there's an ego element and he's the
top-rated
news show you know all these all these
guys are
machismo alpha male type people and
they're you know they want to be number
one tucker's an alpha male you've seen
this [ __ ] were both well i don't
believe that alpha males are a thing i
think that that whole concept is stupid
but they
believe in that that's what i mean
and that's what they see themselves as
so you think tucker sees himself as
alpha well how are you alpha if you tuck
your dick between your legs bro that's
not alpha
not there's anything wrong with it but i
mean it's not alpha it's just ironic
that he tucks his dick which means like
it is yeah that is ironic
he's well he's well known for
his dick tucking habits
we wear them because we have to i can't
possibly imagine putting this out on
television and you know on fox news they
have they have
checks and balances and they have
lawyers and this this is the worst thing
i've ever seen him say and he says a lot
of bad [ __ ] like you know a couple weeks
ago he's talking about white replacement
theory i was like whoa tucker is
becoming like a straight-up white
nationalist but like the more anger the
more outrage
the more views right yes indeed
and i've learned that firsthand you know
that's that's just the truth so
um
let's watch and brace yourself because
this is [ __ ] vile
we did give in this grotesque version of
halloween went on for more than a year
and it's still going on
not even tony fauci still pretends that
masks are medically necessary
he's lying i don't even know what he's
referring to
um
probably
the fact that they're saying that you
know
if you're outdoors and
uh you've been vaccinated then yeah it's
pretty much cool to not wear a mask
yeah but like he's conflating that with
with right that's how he calls him tony
fauci instead of he's about to tony he's
a doctor he's our highest
level medical expert on on
on disease bro and you're going to call
him tony like okay dude
that's doctor tony to you dick tuck
anyway um
yeah he's lying
exactly necessary instead mass are
purely a sign of political obedience
like kim il-sung pins in pyongyang
again it's like what are you talking
about masks are not a sign of political
obedience how are they still saying this
yeah that's the capital of north korea
i know but what does mass have to do
with pyongyang
uh
he's just saying that
you have to people that are wearing the
masks or are bowing down to the
government the way that somebody in
north korea would i guess i mean
i can't really try and pick apart the
analogies on this because i'm trying so
he's sitting here acting like he's doing
something so i'm trying to understand
what this [ __ ] is trying to say
we wear them because we have to the only
people who wear masks voluntarily
outside are zealots and neurotics
come on
i don't feel like a zealot and i wear
one because i want to be safe and also
because i don't want to make people
around me uncomfortable just it just
feels like a common courtesy kind of
thing at this point
yeah you know like they say well fauci
said which i think is a good point the
only reason really to wear well first of
all
usually when i go walk my dogs i don't
wear a mask you know but if i'm gonna be
around people and i know what of course
i'm gonna wear a mask but
um i'm fully vaccinated you know
um but they say you know the optics are
important because we don't we want
people to know it's still important to
wear masks that's what the doctors say
so the perception is important that like
everyone still wear a mask no you don't
know if the people around you are
vaccinated so if i'm fully vaccinated
and i go into a starbucks or something
and there's somebody in there who you
know
is at risk in some way
and they see me they don't know if i'm
vaccinated they could just they could
think that i'm about to give them a
disease like it again it just seems like
it's a simple courtesy there yeah it's
just and there's plenty of people who
are in who cannot get this vaccine
because their immune system is
compromised people are undergoing
chemotherapy who have cancer for example
and of course you know
tuck the dick just wanted them all to
[ __ ] die
covet 19.
uh
you know and they always they always
conveniently forget that in southeast
asia
who have been the most effective at
dealing with this virus
in china
and and uh vietnam
vietnam has been vietnam these
[ __ ] don't have covet because
wearing masks is a huge part of their
culture
new zealand doesn't have covet straight
up no [ __ ] covet
must be nice they don't wear masks you
know why because there's no covert there
um
how neurotic are they
well we know a pew survey from last
march found that 64 percent of white
americans who classify themselves as
liberal or very liberal have been
diagnosed with an actual mental health
condition there you go
i mean guy so like how do we how how do
we live
with somebody who said who's basically
saying here
that lit white liberals are mentally ill
that's why they wear masks the reason
they wear masks
and the reason they do everything is
because they're mentally ill that's the
only justification
what study is he citing by the way
or very little he said
pew research poll or
i mean that didn't even sound like a
study it sounds like a poll so those are
people that
self-report that they have a mental
illness and also you know mental illness
can be depression
i don't think that's really going to
impact your uh cognitive well reasoning
ability liberals are probably people who
tend to be you know
uh
people who are more you know
there's a lot of stigma against mental
health and so i think people
yeah they're more willing to uh they're
probably more open with their like i
would say i struggle with mental health
you know in my life for sure sure
anyone who's honest would say that to be
honest with you like no like tucker is
obviously clearly [ __ ] uh as a
extreme personality disorder i know he's
very normal
he's a very normal man
with his insane joker laughs
right
uh dude i can't believe he just he
literally just said
this [ __ ] this line sent me of white
americans who classify themselves as
liberal or very liberal have been
diagnosed with an actual mental health
condition
i can't get over this line we're all
mentally ill
if you wear a mask you are mentally ill
and you see them everywhere when you
walk down the street in any major city
if you dare to go on foot from union
station to the capitol for example in
washington without wearing a mask
angry biden voters will snort at you in
judgment how could you they're saying i
doubt that i see people with masks
masculine all the [ __ ] time i don't
snort and jolt at them and in l.a a lot
of people wear masks and guess who says
[ __ ] to the people not wearing masks
outside nobody i've never seen anybody
say anything to them
[ __ ] weird fantasy world he lives in
where does he live dc
uh
i would guess new york but to be honest
i don't know
maybe
dc where's he live somebody look that up
i gotta know where this douche [ __ ]
is
right now where he's walking around
people are snorting at him
please take off your mask
[ __ ] you uh was an article from last
year saying he sold his home in dc and
bought a house in florida so he's a
florida guy now he's right at home
oh i'm sure he sees lots of people
getting in fights over you should be
wearing a mask in florida it looks like
his show is taped in new york though
which is what i figured so uh he you
know i mean this dude has multiple
houses he's a he's a trust fund baby
he's an error to a to like a billionaire
fortune or maybe not quite billionaire
he is well he's really successful in it
yeah the uh swanson frozen food this
motherfucker's got swanson money he's
got swanson money
interesting
yeah his full name is uh tucker swanson
mcnear uh carlson oh no wonder he took
the swanston that sounds a little bit
much tucker swanson
[ __ ] the dick swanson
i think he also doesn't necessarily want
people to know that because his whole
shtick is like the everyman thing
but uh he is not every man he is what's
his net worth
basically according to google which of
course you know
can't really trust but
the net worth is
tucker
carlson
is
but i
find that really hard to believe
yeah that doesn't seem very high i'm
sure he makes that much even from fox i
mean what he's got to make more money
than that anyway whatever i'm the gauze
how could you that's the question we
should be asking of them in return the
rest of us should be snorting at them
first they're the aggressors it's our
job to brush them back and restore the
society we were born in so in this
hypothetical dog fight on the street
where people who aren't wearing masks
outside are being attacked by the
society and everybody snorting hordes
according to him
there's a guy without a mask
[Music]
i have never seen that have any of you
guys ever seen that i've never seen a
mass confrontation one way or another no
i've never seen a mass confrontation no
i've actually yeah i've seen people in
public without a mask uh especially you
know earlier in the pandemic when
everybody was a lot more freaked out
about it and did you bark at them like a
dog no i didn't i didn't say [ __ ] but i
gotta say i
gave them a wide berth and stay the [ __ ]
away from them yeah you just knock
around them yeah
i go like this
i spit in their face
so in his hypothetical dog fight
happening everywhere around america
where people are just brawling no we
need to attack them first because we
know what they're thinking
so paranoid
so the next time you see someone in a
mask on the sidewalk or on the bike path
do not hesitate ask politely but firmly
would you please take off your mask bro
can you imagine the [ __ ] balls
if somebody came up to you on the street
and said dude you need to take your mask
off
what happened to personal liberty talk
talk what happened to the conservative
personal freedoms
i can't wear a mask now outside what
what is this insanity he's incur he's
telling his fans
his audience you need to go up to people
outdoors and tell them remove your mask
yo you remember the super spreading
event at the white house that happened
outdoors dip [ __ ]
it happened at an outdoor of that when
your president almost died a covet until
he had like baby stem cells injected
into his [ __ ]
eyes
yeah i mean i think
generally outdoors is is pretty safe but
if there's a lot of people there i mean
i was just looking at the because they
they've been updating the guidelines
since people are getting vaccinated now
and
you know they said if you're outdoors
you're doing activity whatever not
really necessary to wear a mask but say
you go to like a a crowded outfit
yeah exactly uh you can definitely still
catch it there so yeah i mean look at
the white house event with this was the
super spreader you know got transmitted
by like a dozens of people they were
sitting in chairs close together and
you know a lot of people caught covet
but also besides that it's none of your
[ __ ] business dude
it's just such a non-intrusive thing
it's none of your
business good
if people want to wear masks or not why
should that offend you you [ __ ]
snowflake
snowflake outrage right here bro
sjw tucker carlson that social justice
that's what i'm saying these
conservatives turn into the social
justice warriors they don't see it but
they are
i mean this is some zarnish [ __ ] right
like go up to people and say remove your
mask it's offensive to me i dude
i wouldn't know what to say if somebody
said that to me i would just be
flabbergasted no nobody
did
science shows there is no reason for you
to be wearing it your mask is believed
in science
your mask is making me uncomfortable
okay snowflake why is it making you
uncomfortable it doesn't affect you
bro you need to say
they are the snowflakes your mask is
making me uncomfortable
he's so triggered he needs a safe space
against if the masks are triggering tuck
your mask is making me uncomfortable it
looks a lot like the device i used to
tuck my dick behind my legs
i'm very uncomfortable right now
this is this this is the most
i mean this is the craziest [ __ ] i've
ever seen on television almost
please take off your mask for you to be
wearing it your mask is making me
uncomfortable
we should do that and we should keep
doing it until wearing a mask you're a
[ __ ] you would never do that we
we you don't say [ __ ] to anybody [ __ ]
i dare you to go up to some random dude
on the street and i tell them to take
off their mask tell to a big guy too
tough [ __ ] and see what happens you
little [ __ ]
[ __ ] you he's such a [ __ ]
you know he would never say that to
anyone we should we [ __ ] you
such a phony
he is
you aren't saying [ __ ] to anybody talk
and i'm not a tough guy but i feel like
i i feel like even if tuck came up to me
and said that even i who's a little
[ __ ] and probably with coward from any
fight would be like eat [ __ ] taco you
know [ __ ] off
get the [ __ ] out
take your mask off
outside is roughly as socially accepted
as lighting a marble in an elevator
let me back up to really take that one
in wearing a mask outside is roughly as
socially accepted as lighting a marble
in an elevator sorry
[Music]
wearing a mask outside
is as socially accepted as lighting a
marlboro in an elevator he's comparing
wearing masks to secondhand smoke
someone make that make sense i did he's
just saying it's it's as much of a
social faux pas uh
wearing a mask outside
that's i'm
that's what i'm gathering that harms
nobody right you're talking about you're
talking about secondhand smoking you're
talking about hot boxing and elevator
with secondhand smoke
people think this guy's smart
it's repulsive don't do it around other
people
that's the message we should send
because it's true
as we're forcing children to wear mass
outside that should be tucker's going to
be going up to like kids getting
chemotherapy
you know kids who are like super immune
deficient he's in the elevator of the
hospital going down to get some fresh
air he's got a mask on he's like oh [ __ ]
what the [ __ ] are you doing kid i might
as well just light up a cigarette and
hot box this elevator take that [ __ ]
your mask is making me uncomfortable
he's such a [ __ ] piece of [ __ ]
be illegal
your response when you see children
wearing masks as they play should be no
different from your response to seeing
someone beat a kid in walmart
yeah
you see a kid getting the [ __ ] beat out
of him at walmart
you're seeing does carl beat his kids
because i you know what i'm saying like
like think about what he's saying
if i saw a kid getting beat up in
walmart i would find that pretty
disturbing but to him it's like no i see
that all the time just like no different
than putting a piece of cloth on your
face
bruh
dude this is crazy this is the craziest
[ __ ] i ever when you see children
wearing masses they play should be no
different from your response to seeing
someone beat a kid in walmart call the
police immediately contact child
protective services keep calling until
someone arrives
what you're looking at
kids wearing masks
by the way in walmart and most i think
every store in america at this point
they require you to wear masks so carl's
saying go shopping at walmart and call
and you need to call child's productive
services those kids those kids would be
better off in foster care
than parents that take their health
seriously
that is abuse it's child abuse and you
are morally obligated to attempt to
prevent it
if it's your own children being abused
then act accordingly
let's say your kid's school emailed you
to announce that every day after lunch
your sixth grader was going to get
punched in the face by a teacher
stop how would you respond to that
precisely how you should respond when
they tell you that your kids have to
wear masks on the soccer field that is
unacceptable it is dangerous and we
should act like it because it is
but too few of us have responded like
that
not you either [ __ ]
okay so so your child
bro how is he really saying this i don't
get it would you like it if i shot your
child in the face you wouldn't like that
very much would you he's like how would
you respond if your child was being
punched in the [ __ ] face by his
teacher full force
well that's what's happening every day
in america with masks
and this is why i say
i i i don't nobody believes that i don't
think he believes it at all like he'll
just say anything yeah but like well
what about the people watching
some of them i mean
yes exactly people laughing like oh
tucker he's so crazy
no and now
t-minus
you know how many days until
the karen videos of somebody doing
exactly that to people in public oh yeah
i mean that's that's coming he is a
legend
tucker yeah
oh my god i mean it's so upsetting like
damn you know
people are working so hard
you know i mean i've talked about this
but in india they're literally burning
people in the street because
the virus is so out of control there you
know here we've worked hard to get it
under control in america and with
vaccines and social distancing or
wearing masks we've been able to get to
a manageable place in most of the
country
and now it's like
instead of following through and
finishing the [ __ ] job
um
people like this want to sell outrage
meanwhile
in india they're out of medical oxygen
they don't have enough vaccines and
people are dying so fast there's so many
new cases they're burning bodies in the
street that's what's happening in india
please take off your mask i don't
understand their end game i don't i just
don't understand the
the goal here
you know i don't get it
it's it's more attention more more
division more uh polarization so that
you know here's india by the way tucker
here's your utopia
should i show that it's pretty crazy
i don't think you can see bodies you
can't you can't see bodies just wood
burning
but i've seen pictures of like uh you
know
parking lots and streets just full of
bodies on fire because there's nowhere
to there's just so many people dying
scary i saw a video of these poor guys
yesterday where their mom 50 years old
healthy lady
she ran out of medical oxygen and she
passed away
and there's nobody to take her there's
no nobody to do anything they waited
days for somebody to come pick up the
body and what they had to end up doing
is they got on their motorcycle their
little moped and they had to both sit
with their mom's dead body
um
sandwiched between them
and they had to drive her to a morgue
like that
wow
that is really dark
uh tucker should go spend a [ __ ]
weekend in india
please take off your mask before you get
so offended at people wearing masks it's
making me very uncomfortable your mask
is making me very uncomfortable
your mask is making me uncomfortable
now this is dystopian i feel like
i feel like he's working against the
interests of he of humanity he's on the
side
of the robots
i don't know someone you know what i
mean if there's somebody trying to kill
the humans the robot was a terminator
yeah he works for the terminators man
it's kind of baby
he's [ __ ] he's he's on the wrong side
the year is 20 21
a man was sent from the future to
eradicate humanity
his name
tucked the dick carlson
he's undercover as a human agent to send
disinformation and to pit the humans
against each other
so far it's worked almost 600 000
americans have died millions around the
world tucker
i'm so offended when you wear your mask
it's working please take off your mask
people are fighting in the streets and
spitting on each other dog fights over
not wearing masks
[Music]
the end is coming
chuckle carlson reporting it chuckle
carlson journey a journal entry
april 28
2021 i expect i have successfully
convinced
the humans
to not wear masks and to fight each
other
i am now saying that the vaccine
is is can't be trusted and people should
not get vaccinated
call the police immediately i have and
now i am wasting their resources and
having police respond to people wearing
masks on the street pure chaos
i'll report in tomorrow tomorrow i'll be
convincing humans not to eat
tomorrow i'll be convincing humans to
[ __ ] in the street because toilets
aren't safe
the end is clearly here
yeah that's the only that's honestly the
only best explanation i've heard is that
he's a terminator from the future i'll
watch that film
that would be riveting i mean that'd
make a lot that would help me understand
oh
yeah and joe rogan's back at it you know
been [ __ ] on joe here a little bit
joe brogan
but
again
you know
this is the kind of [ __ ] that's just not
acceptable in my opinion and people say
do you think it's safe to get vaccinated
i've said yeah i think for the most part
it's safe to get vaccinated i do i do
but if you're like 21 years old and you
say to me should i get vaccinated i go
no yeah why
i love those guesses like yeah
yeah why why i just said it's safe he
can he joe roger will never
i feel like so many people are trying to
explain to him like this simple [ __ ]
piece of information that he continues
to ignore result and you say to me
should i get vaccinated i go no
no
the way he says it too like
no that is the [ __ ] worst idea
are you healthy
are you a healthy person like look don't
do anything stupid but you should take
care of yourself you should if you do
you're a healthy person and you're
exercising all the time and you're young
and you're eating well and like i don't
think you need to worry about this
okay joe
i don't know how many times i need to
explain this to you i'm sure other
people are trying to make you understand
this too
okay so so listen the [ __ ] up
everybody needs to get vaccinated to
stop the spread of the virus
healthy young people
get the virus
they are asymptomatic and they spread it
to people who are vulnerable
right
it's very [ __ ] simple it seems really
simple yeah like why are we ignoring
this simple [ __ ] fact
um
you know it's not rocket science but
nothing happens
you know also there are and let's be
honest young people do catch the virus
and [ __ ] die
that it's not unheard of or i mean we
just talked about on our show our own
ian he he got the virus he didn't die
but he still has lasting effects from
him his face is still gone and he has
trouble breathing sometimes
here first of all this is a not okay so
joe rogan
i would be more concerned about the
long-term effects of taking alpha brain
which is like basically some dude in a
factory picking up sawdust [ __ ]
formalder hide lead like lead and
asbestos and putting in a pill and
saying it makes your memory better
like you how long you've been taking
that [ __ ] joe i would be more [ __ ]
worried about that than a clinically
trialled
vaccine
that was tried
independently by
every developed country in the world and
has been administered hundreds of
millions if not a billion times by now
um
you know
young people can still catch the virus
and suffer debilitating long-term
symptoms including prolonged shortness
of breath fatigue migraines brain fog
loss of smell or taste
this is a novel virus we don't
understand the lasting term you do not
want this virus trust
trust and listen i'm not a doctor i just
listen to them
right yeah we uh you're right
uh one
1.06 billion vaccines so far
i don't know that i trust a vaccine
that's been administered to over a
billion people
over the course of a year i mean he
opened the statement with i do i think
it's safe i think it's safe he's saying
over and over again he says mostly safe
[Music]
okay so so i have to it begs the
question what are you so worried about
people getting vaccinated you say
should people get vaccinated if they're
20 no
no
why
explain why
explain why they shouldn't get
vaccinated joe
and me
you selling alpha brain there's no
[ __ ] there's no trials there's no
fda
approval there's no assessment of what
the [ __ ] is in those pills that you're
telling your audience to take to enhance
their [ __ ] memory
vaccines no
dmt yes
do we know the long-term uh benefits of
do we know the long-term consequences of
taking dmt like on a regular basis
i don't think that there's been
too many studies he recommends dmt
brain fraud
uh you know
listen i i'm a i'm a proponent of drugs
i try drugs but
i wouldn't recommend taking you know i
wouldn't try and argue with somebody
that it's uh
that it's healthy i would i would
definitely encourage i would say if
somebody
i was like yeah i have a great time at
mdma they say is it's more or less safe
than a vaccine i'd be like oh
the vaccine is definitely safer
vaccine is definitely safer than any
recreational drug yeah yeah that's
pretty true
ah dude what are you doing joe
[ __ ] this guy he's such a meat head dude
i can't yeah i tend to agree with you
but there's a lot of jobs that will tell
you you need to have this well that's
what's starting to happen people are
worried about them doing it for their
children and we talked about this
earlier there's that that you might have
to have your your children vaccinated
and you know i can tell you as someone
who's both both my children got the the
virus it was nothing i wonder who gave
them the virus you piece of [ __ ]
yeah the virus doesn't affect kids very
strongly we know that dude again you're
how after all the time are you missing
the point is to stop the spread
stop the spread
thank you thank you steele stop the
spread right i hate to say that if
someone's children died from this i'm
very sorry that that happened i'm not
i'm not in any way diminishing that but
i'm saying the personal experience kind
of are
you kind of are saying that because
you're saying my personal experience is
the most important thing in the world we
all caught coved nothing happened to us
so i don't think anyone should get the
vaccine and if your kids die and you die
then hey with peace and love i we made
it through because we're healthy and
you're [ __ ] obviously fat or
unhealthy or something that my children
had with code was nothing
one of the kids had a headache the other
one didn't feel good for a couple days
like maybe i mean i don't want my kid
getting a novel virus where we don't
even know the lasting effects thank you
joe
rather stick them with a vaccine which
they've been getting their whole
childhood up to this point
trying to think but nothing happens you
know the real truth the real truth is
joe rogan probably thinks that like you
got autism or something from a vaccine
there's some he has some weird
conspiracy theory that he's not willing
to say
because they keep yeah oh it's not safe
it's not safe why would you do that
why would you take that risk you're not
but they never say what they're afraid
of right i agree i think that that's
underlying this but he either doesn't
want to or perhaps can't because of his
spotify deal um outright say he thinks
it's
you know putting a microchip in you or
giving you autism or whatever it is that
he believes
but yeah there's a there's a
contradiction there that's not being
resolved in his statement it's safe but
you shouldn't take it absolutely
shouldn't take it if you're healthy
right so tell me what's the concern joe
rogan md
i think he's afraid it'll turn into a
beta
oh no anything but that that is actually
he's gonna have to that's what he's
considering alpha brain right
i googled what's in alpha brain i know
we've we talked about it a long time ago
but uh
nootropics what is tell me what's in
alpha brain besides lead i mean i can't
even pronounce formaldehyde uh
sawdust rat droppings
apparently the two uh
well there's a it sounds like there's a
shitload of things in here but um there
are two ingredients that i'm gonna
really struggle to pronounce here
hoopers
[Laughter]
and uh
got vaccinated he's got a lot more
brains than joe rogan
and then by the way this is you know
look this is the same group of people
all these [ __ ] conservative big
brains are all hesitant about
vaccinations for some reason you know
they're they're [ __ ]
they want to get heard okay hold on i'll
get to that just watch this is there any
intention of tracking folks nope
nope
is there any in the vaccine we heard
about an injection of a tracking device
is is is that being done anywhere
yeah on your [ __ ] cell phone dude
i'm sorry i just have to do something
the doctor's like this [ __ ]
there's not a vaccine with a tracking
device embedded in it that i know of
exists in the world
period
is there any intention of tracking these
are our elected leaders guys
jesus [ __ ] christ are people uh
being uh injected with tracking devices
hold on hold on i'm getting a text from
google maps
anyway
let me complain about this tracking
device on twitter right now where i tag
my location let me ask you this is there
possibly a technology that was able to
track your body
manufactured
in the greatest scale we've ever known
and put into a clear liquid that could
be injected into your arm to track your
location which you already do on your
phone
was that able to be um were we able to
do is that what's happening
can you imagine the logistics of of
inventing a tracking molecule that can
fit through a syringe
live in your body
make billions of them
all for the purpose of
doing something that's already that's
already being done to everybody
voluntarily bro the fbi and cia can
listen to me right now like straight up
that's not even that's not even a joke
they can [ __ ] they could listen to me
right now yep
they could be like oh blah blah blah
ethan what's he up to the cia and fbi
can do that they're doing it nsa yeah
with a warrant or without we learn from
snowden they'll [ __ ] just watch me
change
on my phone if i said they're not wrong
here hi fbi
get vaccinated
i'm sorry guys it's just too much
it's just too much for me it's like the
tracking one really pushes me over the
edge too it's just such it's just such a
stupid talking point it's just why do
you need this massive conspiracy to do
something that's already being done
it's already been done
the greatest technological feat
he's paranoid of that he's like yes sir
we're putting tracking devices in the
we're putting tracking devices in the
vaccines all of them yep all of them
your reports are true you're the
facebook post you read
russian propaganda on facebook it's true
maybe tucker carlson brought them from
the future with technology and the year
is 2021.
my name is tucker carlson
i come
give me that music zack
year is 2021
the name
agent tucker carlson terminator version
69 420.
i am infiltrated the humans and put
futuristic devices to track their
location in each vaccination
the only problem is
now i've been too good at convincing
people not to get the vaccine
and so we can't get the tracking beacon
in them
please take off your map i can't get my
talking point straight do we want the
vaccine or not
please take off your mats
the humans watch my show
[Music]
and uh
i'm sending back money i'm just an
immigrant robot sending back money to my
family in the future for the future
[Music]
he's here to buy bitcoin
i'm here to buy bitcoin before it blows
up
[Music]
tucker's on the next level man so then
our favorite people converge
uh tucker defense joe of course um
so we have a perfect crossover perfect
anime crossover as they say
in which he says
surprise surprise more of the most
heinous uh low brain [ __ ] never
you want to feel me do you sit in
hindsight in your chair hit record
that's it
jack you want the chair you could have
the chair i told you no because then you
called dibs on it first then i'd look
like the ass oscar i called dibs on it
yeah okay
we i went to the bathroom and we're
having another fight here we're not
having a fight we're just talking about
what what's going on guys
ian was very nice to offer his help
for me to move in a couple days and
he's like you know i'm putting that
offer out there but i really hope i
don't have to help you like a larry
david seinfeld moment you know sure yeah
please don't ask me but and then a b a b
is like you know that's what you get for
trying to help a friend out what were
the words exactly well i said it doesn't
matter when you're sincere because when
you see her you just get [ __ ] over as
well how do i know you were sincere
you wanted to film it
who got [ __ ] over
i mean i was just trying to be a good
friend and now i'm being called a cloud
goblin ah i see yeah i see i see
well
and now zach's upset about this chair
i'm not upset about the change
now there's a new thing so
razor so we got a bunch of free gaming
chairs that razer was kind enough to
send me
so i was like does anyone want a gaming
chair
now ian was quick on the draw ian
immediately was first like i'll take it
smart man for his but i will say and you
guys hmm you guys tell me what you think
about this
now listen i'm happy to give the chair
out to whoever wants it i didn't expect
this whole drama to unfold so but i'm
just putting this out there you guys can
tell me if i'm off base or not
if it's for ian's girlfriend
he is not sitting on that chair right
now then i don't know if it holds the
same priority
as a direct crew member
lino's part she's a part-time employee
i'm just putting that out there that's
true sam has uh she's she's been helping
out behind the scenes and some things
she helped us on frenemies yeah yeah
yeah so i
know a crew member to backing up on that
point yes like you said
he called dibs on it first and i
messaged him privately yesterday saying
you know what man to be fair you called
dibs on it first yeah a lot of the law
dibs is pretty awesome yeah exactly i'm
just putting that out there i don't
believe that
just trying to
talk this all out
so ian is good we all agree
ian's good but one question comes on the
second chair
when i said i have another chair who
wants it now here's the thing zach is
moving out on his own
right
he's about to move into a new place
the chair would be nice to christen a
new apartment it really would it'd be
fantastic but maybe called dibs on it
okay so hold up hold on the roll of dibs
now hold doesn't hold sovereignty
well he's sitting all high and mighty
and he's in the chair actually yeah
i think it's a [ __ ] you to me i think
that's what it is okay
i got this chair so i can leave look at
you sitting back types of arguments okay
so let me get the logistics right so
i was trying to be kind well first of
all zach you forget to mention that on
this saturday said zach if someone else
takes the other one you could have the
one that i have did i not say that
multiple times he did but then but but
but then you put me in a predicament
where i look like an [ __ ] because oh
yeah you look like an [ __ ] right he's
not gonna actually take you up on that
offer a.b i know what zach means
yeah i mean
why would i do that
it'd be the same kind of [ __ ] if you
if you actually took me up on my offer
to help you move which was completely a
token offer
well i in fact i do need your help to
move
[ __ ] yeah you're such an [ __ ]
[Laughter]
so i went straight i was the second
person to ask but i'm being questioned
now foreign
i will say
that ab respectfully waited to call dibs
on the second chair
zach where were you when the dibs were
taking place were you not on your phone
what happened it was i believe it was a
chat late at night and
it wasn't that late bro
i i go to bed it's relatively early
exactly 9 30. is that some little baby
he just didn't go to bed 9 30 yeah yeah
dude i go to bed early
and that's late that's late for him
what's wrong with you why would you go
to bed at 9 30. you're like a young man
why are you doing this i wake up
relatively early um what time he does he
wakes up he's like a responsible adult
he wakes up he's not responsible that's
neurotic that's way too early what time
do you wake up
i'm usually up at six i i like working
in the morning and he wakes me up at
seven
wait okay so nine to six
you sleep from nine to six
that seems like too many it's uh what
nine hours it's nine hours no it's a
little more than average but yeah nine
to six
right okay i guess that's fine
why
you have to go to bed at nine to wake up
at six bro well no i don't i don't have
to go to bed i i mean
my body clock wakes me up at six seven
o'clock no matter i mean i'll be out at
night of staying up till three in the
morning and i'll be up at six yeah
yeah
so i put the dib call out and at first
there was crickets i said nobody wants
these chairs
ian comes in he says i'll take one if
nobody else wants a b waits a beat and
he says i'll take the other one
look i i'm i'm mad that a b got it
because he just can't own up and fess up
to his own [ __ ] but what did he do
like the whole the whole spiel last week
he won a minute i'm gonna [ __ ]
twilight zone i don't even know what's
going on anymore
wait but but there is a genuine i feel
that aby's being genuine when he says
that he thinks you're the one that
brought it up
like i feel like you're both genuinely
think the other person brought it up
he did bring it up on a stack of bibles
if i had one a stack of them
i'll do it on my
i'm gonna buy you a thousand bibles to
sit upon you're jewish man how much
weight does that really hold okay get me
a couple torres okay there you go and
then i know i believe that you both are
being sincere and saying the other
person brought it up
yeah that story has changed so many
times i mean how has it changed how is
it cheating
let me ask you this when i said
forget forget
the message i sent you when i said
i don't know if i offered yet
but i could help you move
you you you knew what you know so your
argument is that i brought it up prior
in a phone call right you did yes this
is watergate this this so why would i
say i don't know if i offered yet about
helping you move
what
his message says i don't know if i
offered yet but if you need any help
with the move
you know the message before you said
let's finish well hold on a b you're
saying i don't know if i offered yet it
could be perceived as you know you've
offered before
thank you thank you finally someone too
it
it could go either way i'm just saying
right but i saw i had this whole we had
this whole discussion about oh yeah we
should film it as well
but i'm saying the filming thing i feel
like we have to we have to
say the truth is out there but we don't
know what it is it's like roshaman yeah
it's i think you both are being sincere
but now we move on to the the chair
issue
zach do you believe abey's wronged you
in taking the chair
i feel like he could have said you know
what zack i'm gonna be a good guy like
i've always been a good guy
and i'm still being a good guy
you know what you believe a b should
have not claimed the chair knowing that
you would have wanted that for your new
apartment i feel he should have the like
okay
yeah yeah yeah essentially yes
yeah i don't know man
is it i
is it maybe a little bit of misdirected
anger here too because
i mean
ian's the one that said
he would take a chair if nobody else
wants it and somehow he wound up with it
it sounds like he wanted it i'm not mad
at ian and i well ian's not even sitting
in the chair that's what i'm saying oh
he is he
grabbed it real fast
i gotta be honest that once
we got it in here i sat on it and i said
to sam i think i might want this chair
you said sam has back problems which is
why i'm like okay you know what oh you
want the back problems she does if she
was here i'd bring her in which is fine
which is cool man i i look i get back
problems
abey should have no like you know i
thought like okay you know zack's moving
you know what i play you know
can i say something i have
i have an observation real quick there
there were two chairs
i said i will take a chair
a b says i will take a chair
the math is done it's over here hold on
hold on a chair would look great in my
place out of nowhere there's no he's
coming to pick a fight i feel like
you're skewing this narrative a little
bit ian you didn't say i'll take a chair
you said i'll take a chair for sam if
nobody else wants one that's a very
different type of i don't think he said
that in the moment and and at the time
we thought there was one chair he did
say that we thought there was one chair
at the time then ethan after he's like
well we have two of them
i thought i said a picture of two of
them he used her ian claimed one
and then i was like [ __ ] that yeah i'll
take the other one give me of course you
are you should have known like hey
zach's moving today now the way the way
that they were acquired is interesting
right because lena
comes to our house all the time now amy
did you take the chair did lina
lina see that's not fair so she's there
yeah so here's what's interesting is
that lena is here all the time every day
dropping stuff off for us from teddy
fresh
and so
sh
like it was real quick like boom chair
done
but okay he called dibs what's
interesting is when this conversation
came up yesterday when zach was starting
to be like
having a little bit of uh regrets
ian messaged me directly and says i'm
coming to get the chair at 10 am wow
[ __ ] exposed dude
well again to backing up i messaged him
so there's no workplace conflict because
i i think you know being on the same
page is very
important um you know what i'm going to
do zach
i'm going to buy you one of those chairs
for a housewarming present oh wow you
don't have to that's very sweet of you i
mean if you want to give me a b's
[Laughter]
i literally told him take it i said it's
too big for me okay but do you see
you don't even like it now
i like it it's just it's really like i
don't know i feel like it's really big
for my living room you see that makes me
look like a complete [ __ ] if i were
to hold on hold on hold on a b doesn't
even like the chair he's offered it to
you zach
is this sincere or is it is it here is
this sincere or is this me being a good
friend and saying i don't like it so you
could have it who knows i mean
why are you sitting all high and mighty
in it like oh mr chairs i'm literally
slumped
let me ask some questions here
a b
how would you rate this chair on a scale
of one to ten
it's up there i'd say [ __ ] yourself
really it's probably a 10.
oh you it's all yours it's still
comfortable huh wait it's like
it's a 10 he says zach
so it doesn't sound like you really do
want to give it up
i mean
be honest for once
he's making it very hard but uh
yeah no i mean i could live without it
you could live without it
okay but but if i take the chair
i look like an [ __ ]
i'll tell you what well hold on that's
not necessarily true
okay wait so
ian is sending receipts now because
both zach a b and myself all said if
nobody wants it i will take it that
wasn't just me
all three people are doing this weird
you uh it's all you know okay but i'm
not i'm not going after you proceeds
let me show the original okay so we have
zach
can you zoom in a little bit
oh yeah well zach comes in at 9 00 p.m
zach what's going on you should be
asleep well bedtime's 9 30. but that's
what i'm saying you were awake when this
was all going down
okay i got the time wrong a b said i'll
take if nobody wants it at 5 00 p.m
so all three parties said i will take it
if nobody wants to we're so humble yeah
yeah you immediately
you all just had a conversation about
how i said that like two minutes ian
where's your message
that you where's your message
your receipt it's very conspicuous not
now i'm a little like if you you know
because you're receiving establishment
can i read the messages
can i can i read the messages of the
chat of me and ian last night then ian's
response okay let's just get all the
information before we make it okay so
zach sent this this is zach
at 10 45 p.m i sent that to zach last
night
okay that's that's from you that's from
ian that is from me to zach last night
wait what is this message i'm reading it
says okay this is from ian to zach okay
let's
chance last chance final offer let the
record show that the chair is sitting
there waiting for you to take it if you
so choose if you decide to pick it up
just let me know otherwise we will grab
it in the am
that's
that's pretty slam dunk sack
i sent that to zach i said if you want
it take it i'm just clarifying well
that's fair but here's the thing you i'm
not mad at you you call dibs on it first
like i i have no issue with you or sam
taking it sounds like this is really
this isn't necessarily about the chairs
now this is interesting okay
here's when ian at 455
claims one chair
he says sam will take it
if nobody else wants it okay right
and he that was the first response that
was 4 55.
sam will take it if no so he was upfront
about the fact that it wasn't for
himself so so he gets points for that
for sure
which is fine
i like sam i like you ian
ian made a pretty definitive offer that
it was yours for the taking and it
sounds like you don't want the one he
has you want the one a b wants right
that is an interesting observation again
you want a b share you don't want ian's
chair again okay again again
i would be an [ __ ] if if i took it
from ian who he he sent that message on
purpose
but he he's deep down he's all please
don't take this chair please don't take
this check were you hoping you didn't
take idiot
no both sam and i had a conversation
because i got the vibe that zach really
wanted the chair for zach he just wants
a chair so bad and we were like
just take it i i even said no but you
wanted it like don't don't like it
that's on you zach yeah that's on you
because i want to be a good guy i don't
want to be in and out you want credit
for being a good guy that's what you
want well i i feel like i did some good
guy moves no
look at this rift that you've created
look at this now this is my private
message exactly we have more
go ahead it says if ian takes the other
one then you can have mine for real
don't worry about it wow
dude
show it all zach is saying there's a
message above
what's the message above you're like bro
you need to hop on that chair
what hold on the message above is a zoom
call it's a zoom call well zac you send
it then if you got something let's see
it yeah what you got zach is anybody
willing to give their chair to zach i am
willing to even though he's uh
you just think i don't want it
because it's not a great you feel it's
not a sincere offer
correct if someone's like you know what
zack
i want to give you my chair you want me
to kiss your feet and say take this 500
chair i want you to i guess kiss my feet
and admit that you came up with the idea
to film first
i'll tell you what you there it is
this is what i was supposed to do
this is what i was handing out this is
not about the channel it's not about the
chairs it's not about the chair
is it a cool chair yes would it look
great in my new apartment absolutely
but
if i take it from ian or sam or ab
say i'm gonna look like i can buy you i
will spend my own money to buy you this
chair as a housewarming president well
it's very sweet everybody gets the chair
everybody wins i don't get why zach
feels entitled to a chair just because
he's moving i didn't go
i just moved i didn't get a [ __ ]
chair
do you want a chair no exactly dan did
anyone else at all yeah did anyone who
had dibs ask you if you wanted it
because they felt like i actually
deserve it i i was the first person to
get the offer because i was here at the
house when they arrived and i was like
no i'm good i i have a nice chair at
home thank you abe says dan do you want
a chair i feel you should get dibs dan
says simply no no
i'm above it i'm above all material
wants what what kind of chair do you
have i am in love okay listen listen
listen
ian and ab have said no we will not
offer our chairs to zach in this moment
we've you've missed that whoa you've
missed your opportunity
you've both offered previously
both offered previously zach declined
in this moment is anybody going to step
up and make a gracious true offer to
zach i'm tired of offering this chair to
zach exactly the seventh time yeah you
want the chair seventh time what the
[ __ ] you need seventh he doesn't want it
he doesn't want to take it we're trying
he doesn't want to because okay
all right i i feel i i didn't take the
chair because i sacrificed for the
sanctity of our work relationship but
it's falling apart don't you see
you're holding you're resentful that
they got the chair yeah yeah
that may have been your intent and your
intent may have been pure but you you're
having the opposite effect you're
tearing this family apart right now
could i could i hold it a little ammo
against a b
maybe
right
let me you let me rub my naked ass all
over this chair and then i'll give it to
you and it's a win-win i'll be satisfied
i'll be satisfied knowing that and you
get a new chair okay okay all right let
me summarize zach i'm gonna buy you a
chair done well you don't have to do
that i wanted to get you a housewarming
present
and i'm glad
that um i found
a good gift for you okay well thank you
that's very sweety i don't have to do
that though it does sound like you are
harboring some resentment towards a b
well i just feel like you know he lied
last week and then he gets this chair
like
you know well it wasn't right it was
okay
yeah you guys have some do you guys talk
uh you guys you guys need counseling
yeah you guys need some counseling i
think
this is
some
rocky uh some rocky water everybody gets
a chair dan you don't do you want a
chair no i i'm not i've got a nice chair
all right you see that
well thank you ethan that's very sweet
yeah
you're very welcome and i hope you all
enjoy your
chairs god bless thank you i know a b
will i wonder if razer will send me
another chair so i have to buy it
i'll just send him this clip and just
say nothing and see what happens
you don't have to buy me another i'm
buying you the chairs see he's rejecting
a chair again
because i have something here's the
thing though i have something called
jewish guilt and i think ethan you can
you can attest to this where it's like
you have to be a mensch and a good guy
right
ethan you got any of that jewish guilt
listen i i know i know the impulse
you're talking about
i'm gonna buy you the chair well thank
you that's very sweet of you
okay
b will you accept would you rather a b
get the new chair and you get a beast
chair
nah he rubbed his ass all over it so you
want the new chair not yet
not yet i don't know what you've done in
that chair
you've definitely jerked off in that
chair it'd be don't lie it's been like
it's been like eight hours that's it
that's all it takes
yeah he he wants that chair
okay the case is closed
zach is getting a chair
dan is an adult who buys his own chairs
and uh but listen they're spare chairs
they're spared their chairs for spare
and everybody gets one well thank you
so are you keeping the chair ian or is
sam getting it
it's i'm gonna let sam use it that was
that was actually serious where i said
her old chair gave her
an aching backs oh well that's fantastic
we'd love to do what we can to help uh
sam's back that's an honor yes
i want to make it clear
i want to make it clear how much of a
saint i am and how kind i'm the same
well i'm the same well you know
that's true i think i might be the same
dan i've never risen above i've
transcended the chair debate well
they're my chairs okay let's let's get
that back straight
i'm the scapegoat
av is always the scapegoat for a b
a b takes heat for everything
and a lot of it is undeserved
thank you dan and a lot of it is
deserved yeah it does seem like a lot of
that
that was the implicit i'll support that
statement part of the statement i mean
let's not forget that a b did show a
text of you saying you should film it
like let's like not [ __ ] leg i'm
fully i i'm
zach i love you but i am 100 on a b side
of the uh the filming debate oh it feels
so good until you come up with some
receipts until you come up with some mo
he has no receipts by his own admission
we'll get it in writing next time buddy
lesson learned you we could we could
turn into this well hold on we could
possibly subpoena the phone company
i'm going to do that i'm going to hit up
verizon i'll be like you got the
recordings yeah do you like to have a
warrant
yeah under h3 jurisdiction yeah the
content course ethan
they shoot a warrant to subpoena abe's
phone records
the honorable judge
now that's a content card i would watch
amy's phone record subpoena under
warrant
only person calls me zach
well because i care i genuinely care how
are you doing i care about our work i
know it's sweet
it's sweet oh it's sweet
i love going to sleep at six and being
woken up at seven it's very sweet what
the [ __ ] you stay up all night like what
like
that's another thing ab your sleep
schedule is not very compatible with
work although you've not been late
no i work i mean i work
my work's always done
yeah but what time did you start work
be honest with me
what time did you start working on that
powerpoint
oh the powerpoint was late but that's
because we decided to do it yesterday
and also just because of ramadan my
schedule's a little off
because like i don't eat all day i don't
have the energy to do anything then i
eat and then i get tired for a little
bit and usually i'll take a nap for like
an hour or two
you still you're still calling fast
what is it you're still holding fast
yeah no water during the day this whole
time no water how many days in are you
15 and 15 halfway there halfway there
baby
nice look i will say abe does he's the
hardest worker i know he works excuse me
i'm right here dude yeah thanks dude
excuse me what do i do
zack does always tell me maybe by zach's
[ __ ]
maybe by comparison to what zach does in
a day
he's the only person he knows
okay
all right everybody
i'm glad we could uh we i think i don't
know if we made things better or worse
but hey zach got it jack's getting a
chair out of it right well thank you
what are you doing that old chair
what'd you say what are you doing with
that old chair zach
this old chair yeah the red one i don't
know
can i have it dana
there was something in this one he said
that was really good but hey oh about
the the herd immunity [ __ ] oh yeah wait
hold on it's in the very beginning yeah
it was pretty it's pretty good again
harvard educated race lady now you're
really confusing us
if you've gotten a vaccine
why is other people's refusal to get the
vaccine a problem for you again this is
another point that keeps saying which is
so willfully ignorant
if the vaccine is so effective why are
the people who choose to get it mad at
the people who choose not to get it
huh
do people who've slimmed down from
gastric bypass yell at fat people on the
street fat people do not spread a
contagious disease
and actually they do demi lovato just
did that last week right right actually
yes apparently demi lovato does do that
but your analogy is horrible because fat
people if being fat is not contagious
i left that yogurt store and didn't get
the yogurt that i wanted right
well that is a them yeah
and then i had a hard time the rest of
the weekend right
i'm so sorry that happened to her damn
it's so tragic my heart has been
bleeding for her
you wouldn't think so it's not really
their business your body your choice
remember
but your body your choice is definitely
not the standard with the covid vaccine
with the covid vaccine it's your body
msnbc's choice watch this guy explain
except when it comes to wearing masks
this guy cannot keep a simple this was
literally on his show the night after he
was making that rant about the mass that
we just talked about there's no
consistency bro you literally talking
about ripping people's masks off their
face and calling child protective
services on people who have their kids
wear masks
i don't know how we get to hurt immunity
unless we normalize the framework around
vaccine certification listen we're doing
it in colleges some organizations are
doing it we're in a global crisis we
have to reach herd immunity and the
carrot and stick of
you get the vaccine you'll be able to
participate in travel
restaurants you name it because that's
frankly easier for small businesses to
to adhere to
herd immunity
boy it seems like not so long ago it was
back in the 50s or like last week that
using the phrase herd immunity was
enough to get you yanked off the air as
an anti-faxer okay so this is my
favorite um tucker
talk to dick carlson is talk is he
thinks that
he was a proponent of
everybody gets coveted and we get heard
of immunity from millions of people
perishing from catching
this guy is talking about herd immunity
through vaccination right the humane way
that's how we're actually going to get
rid of this virus
and he actually thinks that those are
the same thing he thinks that this guy's
a hypocrite for wanting to achieve herd
immunity through vaccination
because tucker wants people to just
catch covet
can you imagine
being saying this
your body your choice he's making fun of
that the guy okay i'm enough enough [ __ ]
that guy
oh there's a nut i'm sorry guys but like
there's so much [ __ ] i have to talk
about it you guys heard about this whole
thing now about like uh joe biden's
climate plan includes cutting 90 of red
meat from our diets by 2030. oh this of
course comes from lauren bobert is that
i say your name right
uh i think so the q and on
uh
[ __ ] for brains
uh representative she's gotta be from
florida right where is she from no uh i
believe she's from uh colorado oh yeah
colorado's good too
she's the one unless
because there's there's her and there's
the majority taylor green lady right and
i get them kind of conflated i think
bobert though is the one
that had
the
the restaurant where all the waiters uh
are armed and like carrying handguns for
some reason and famously um had like
multiple food poisoning incidents where
they gave diarrhea to like 300 customers
on mass
it's awesome
uh wow that let me uh
though because
hopefully that's not the other one well
anyway she's one of these like
conspiracy theory uh psycho uh
republicans that's becoming more and
more normal she says joe biden's climate
plan includes cutting 90 of red meat
from our diets by 2030. they want to
limit us to about four pounds a year why
doesn't joe stay out of my kitchen and
the basis for this nothing it's totally
false joe biden doesn't want to cut your
meat conception obviously if you had a
[ __ ] brain cell you would know this
doesn't make any sense and of course it
doesn't make any sense also
also just to supplement this information
her pork sliders allegedly poisoned
dozens of people at a local rodeo there
you go
home with bloody diarrhea yeah they
didn't follow any uh health codes
whatsoever and they gave like a giant
amount of people i was right about her
having the restaurant and the restaurant
by the way was called shooters
shooting [ __ ] bloody turds out my ass
who needs a weapon when you're
when you're uh selling the the poison
you imagine going to
going to a restaurant where your waiter
just has a nine millimeter on their hip
for some reason like that's the gimmick
anyway she's just made this up basically
and you know
it was uh
it all apparently originated from uh the
good old daily mail
our favorite
the daily mail well obviously it's not
true she says stay out of my kitchen
okay nobody wants to be in your kitchen
you're causing bloody diarrhea remember
everybody's staying out of your kitchen
but not because of joe it's because
you've
you
serve bad food
and so now all these [ __ ] big brain
conservatives are back at it again with
[ __ ] here on fox news of course guys
i mean oh it can't be played
the internet archive has failed me
no
because they took it down let me try one
more time oh it worked oh there you go
nope it doesn't work son of a [ __ ] did
they retract the story uh
[Music]
i guess it's very possible as it was
completely debunked as being [ __ ]
how would that even work okay now
you got your beef you got your beef beef
raisins start rationing we got beef
tickets
here know your way around some meat i
was trying to think of a funny tweet
like uh
joe biden is limiting us to one square
of toilet paper per [ __ ]
oh that'd be tragic
that that's something worth getting
upset about stay out of my bathroom joe
and then conservatives
or whoever people that are upset about
it they start posting photos of their uh
of their wives
joe biden you're gonna take away my
toilet paper i used two rolls to wipe
this [ __ ] what do you think about that
very soon you go to hell
damn
i ain't taking no steaks from that man i
just love that she says stay out of my
kitchen the woman who actually gives
people a bloody diarrhea cooking so bad
it's awesome
yeah
the truth biden has not proposed any
limit on america's red meat consumption
in fact he has not proposed any limit on
any americans consumption of food
obviously
yeah i believe this all originated from
him setting some goals
for uh climate change purposes and but
no not sharing any details and then the
daily mail went and found
some paper from the university of
michigan i believe
that uh
explained
one of the ways that we could get carbon
emission down is by cutting
our meat consumption yeah not only did
that have no
association with joe biden it was
actually published before joe biden was
even president
right they just found some random study
and we're like
look this is what he wants to do
dan's a good man oh thanks joe
i do think you're going to hell like
wally but that's all right
hey hey come on
the year is 2021
i am a terminator
my name is lowen berber
the name the name
is
the name is berber what are you calling
her loin bober bobert
i was sent from the future to destroy
humanity
i started by poisoning everyone that
came to my restaurant but the poison
wasn't strong enough they only [ __ ]
blood
now i'm trying to convince everybody
that global global climate change is a
hoax
and i'm encouraging everybody to eat as
much meat and to use as much energy and
to waste and burn trees as much as
possible we're trying to meet you we are
trying everything as possible
to eradicate humans if not through covet
than through climate change
i'm making meats now smoking these meats
here
mark zuckerberg is also an asset he's
smoking so many meats that the climate
has raised a full half degree just from
zuck smoking meats
on the meat shop
zuckerberg is doing excellent work to
ending humanity
the t3 billions is doing a great job
humanity will soon be extinct
signing out low and boger
meet jeff
ceo of shooters
diary bloody diarrhea sliders
[Music]
i
listen guys i'm just talking about [ __ ]
that really grinds my gears that's all
i've ever done on this show that's all
i've ever done in my career and i'm not
stopping now just because it's some
[ __ ] it just because it's like the
people that are really talking [ __ ]
are the ones that are in politics you
know what i mean they don't get an
exemption just because they're not doing
pranks on youtube [ __ ] them
like you said you're just you're just
doing the sjw thing in 2021 exactly
that's it i'm tucker carlson exactly
your masks make me very uncomfortable
[Music]
and i'll keep going [ __ ] it caitlyn
jenner is running for goddamn governor
the woman who
i'm i don't understand caitlyn jenner
she's like a staunch republican
she supports the party that literally
hates transgender people i mean she's
like a super supporter of donald trump
who
passed a law discriminating against or
not passed law but he made an executive
order
discriminating against trans people in
the military he said if you're trans you
cannot certain legends around and and
caitlyn jenner is like cool
i mean it doesn't make any sense
by the way
if you guys don't know there's like a
recall of our governor here in
california gavin newsom and so caitlyn
jenner was like i'll do it
so she's going to be on the ballot
she'll be the first transgender governor
of california um
has there ever been a transgender
person you are a transgender oh
a governor of some kind or like even
elected official has there been a
transgender yeah elected official for
sure but uh but uh
uh
yeah not not certainly not governor
yeah
not that we know of
i suppose that's true
she is a staunch supporter of donald who
hates uh basically i'm just he doesn't
like
correct me if i'm wrong um ian since all
things kardashian are your realm of
knowledge and you you follow it so
closely
he's like what the [ __ ] are you talking
about that's not true you know that i
mean i agree with dan ian
follow everything closer i know i was
being i was being a facetious please
stand up stand up please ian but i don't
think caitlyn jenner voted uh for trump
in 2020 i think uh well hold on it's a
big it's a better story than that
she voted for him in 2016 but not 2020.
no that's not what is that wrong okay
i've got the details here got it
equality california i don't know who
they are but they say this the oh they
say they're the nation's largest
statewide lgbtq plus civil rights
organizations they said of a caitlyn
jenner's run make no mistake we can't
wait to elect a trans governor of
california but caitlyn jenner spends
years telling the lgbtq community to
trust donald trump we saw how that
turned out now she wants us to trust her
hard pass burned
nice
alright so let's just
have some fun here now and talk about
the luxury pranks
this is the
overlooked by me
uh
one of these classic pranksters
it's a prank bro right
this is something that apparently he's
making here let's watch this one i saw
uh this is a typical breakdown of his
videos here look you guys are gonna be
so for this episode we posted an ad in
the missed connection section on
craigslist claiming to be a 16 year old
girl several older men responded to this
ad who are interested in meeting up with
her despite thinking that she was 16
years old out of the several older men
who responded we invited one to our set
today we did our research and found out
the man that we invited here today is in
his mid-30s we're going to have our
decoy actors from victoria
[Music]
then why
what about this is uh
a sexual for you ben i mean come on i
don't know
it's not a pro 16 year old girl who
posted this ad notice that she's
actually 21 in real life let's see what
this man's intentions are behind meeting
up with the girl that he thinks is 16.
we just need to set up the cameras and
get to work are you ready chester
let's get the work
that was good
yeah
no it wasn't was it
it wasn't i don't know
it's sort of like his catch phrase
chester always does that oh chad okay oh
gesture so bear in mind that this is
meant to be real okay
now
i'm [ __ ] in disbelief that
bro this is just a strange world we live
in here here he's arriving
got a heartbeat on effect
so a dude
covered in duct tape
what
um dress has a uh he's wrapped in duct
tape in a bunny
outfit and he's just hopping towards her
what are you doing
yeah this is can you stop this is unreal
dude
um can somebody please help
excuse me
i am hero entrance this is real belief
about this right now this is real
according to them
sir what's going on here
sir what's going on here this isn't
normal behavior why are you dressed up
like this
yeah what are you doing stop
okay all right dude stop i'm chris
hanson with dateline nbc
i really don't know what to do i'm
speechless honestly
yo
sarah are you on
drugs let's go come on
they lower him in and just walk back
so they get him they lure him into the
bedroom door closed got him
and he starts
screaming
how does this
end oh it doesn't really
i i i'm blown away by this video
i didn't watch this in advance because i
i wanted to be surprised i'm
i can't believe what i'm watching this
is but people so much worse than
anything i've ever seen yeah
so this video has seven million views
overwhelming like majority people and
let me go in the comments and see what
people are saying
i mean yeah people think it's real
i don't know how you were so calm i
would have started swinging he goes sir
what are you doing this is very unusual
behavior
did you bring condoms did you bring
condoms
um
man
do people really believe this are they
just suspending their disbelief i mean
people believe
the uh
the j station videos and that's really
just kind of lowered my bar
a lot i mean
we are so doomed as you is i've talked
about all this [ __ ] about the t-100 is
sent back to try to kill humanity
and the fact that people can watch this
and not have a skeptical
skeptical thought in their head
if you let it play out a little longer
there's like the fakest
phone call ever to the police oh really
guys
guys let's hear the phone call at the
one part i don't know if you even knew
what he was doing in the first place
i think it's before it's before that
yeah
it's after they're holding the door
subscribe
what causes that
click right here
sonic.exe guys clearly on drugs dude
what can i do
what can i do
i mean
at the one part i don't know if he even
knew what he was doing in the first
place
a jake paul poster on the wall in the
background yeah that's that's their
elaborate set this is where they so
where's the phone call right here
no it's it he doesn't actually make a
phone call but he says
are you going to call the police
and his friend's like oh yeah i'm
calling the press
what's up rick
yeah it's like right after it's like
here
also the guy's like banging on the door
then he just like let's let's go
[Music]
dude he's
are you clearly
the police
yeah dude i'll call him oh yeah yeah
yeah yeah dude call him because he's
clearly on
if drugs even a child should know this
is fake i don't know what to say
i don't know if i should even stop
trying to talk let's like what what's
the point
well it's dude i'm freaking scared it's
funny to see how much parker the main
guy defends it defends that it's true
oh he's willing to die on that hill huh
oh big time
oh i closed the power point let me
reopen it
why are they called luxury pranks so
those don't seem very yeah nothing about
that seemed luxurious here we got
another uh to catch a predator
yeah this is just a short super cut
basically this is a 25 year old who's
obsessed with
trains okay
okay
what do you got there i got my train oh
okay i have a train by the way there's
no way if this was real that they would
be comfortable just confronting these
people in tiny rooms without anybody
be like oh he oh call the police
they would be dead by now probably this
was real
they were asked about that in an
interview and he goes well we have 9-1-1
on speed dial
that's the dumbest thing ever we have
911 on speed dial
we all have 9-1-1 everyone has an i-1
and speed dial that's the whole point
you're going to call the police
immediately
[Applause]
it's really okay
are you sure call the police please
please please man i already have a
charge man like please
for what i was peeing
and it apparently was in front of a
and some of the kids caught me yeah
does this one have a lot of views too
the train [ __ ]
yeah so they deleted a bunch of their
videos on their original channel after
they got demonetized and after they were
on the news for being fake oh they were
so this they're on the average
yeah they're on the news
one
they were investigated
because
of one of their videos because they
claimed it was real and so investigators
looked into it uh-oh
yeah i have it in the slideshow a little
bit they got lost in the sauce so here
they are denying they're saying no
they're insisting it's all real
and an interview with leon lush
it seems so glaringly obvious to me that
just a little bit of common sense
through watching a lot of your videos
would suggest
that something's going on that's not
completely real if something seems like
that like i said dude i will buy your
flights for you to come out here and see
how a video is filmed i'm 100 okay with
that you should check on that
all the child predators in your videos
are legit child predators
[Music]
it depends i mean do it i mean what what
do you classify as uh what do you
classify as a child
i don't know parker you're the expert
here man
what do you i mean someone somebody that
somebody that tries to show up and like
have sex with a 15 year old girl that's
what seems to be the premise of all of
your videos are they being paid to be on
a show or are they actually think
they're going to meet up with the girl
with the possibility of it
this is what this is
it seems so glaringly like
so stupid
uh the police get involved that's
interesting local station
are they proof that it isn't real why do
we even go
viral video of alleged sex offenders not
real you don't say
if they have proof though two men claim
to be exposing inappropriate access by a
sex offender in amherst and town awanda
now the video
is a hoax two on your side's michael
wooten has verified information from
investigators
he's taking pictures outside chuck e
cheese right off the top we can verify
this video is not real our source is the
amherst police department which says the
publisher of the video admitted it was
fake unfortunately many of the millions
of viewers weren't in on the joke here's
the back story these two guys claim
someone asked them to investigate a
sexual predator who moved into the north
towns this man was found with thousands
of images of child pornography on his
computer and he also committed an act of
assault on a minor they claim the man
dude you can't lie about that [ __ ]
of course the police get involved you're
like oh this dude has has illegal as
like hordes of child pornography that's
like a serious that's like fbi [ __ ]
and only serves seven months behind bars
so they wanted to follow him around to
find incriminating evidence to send him
back to jail the video shows the man
whose face is blurred buying happy meals
at mcdonald's
this is beyond
as all predators do just stocking up on
happiness
to keep in my glove box
children outside chuck e cheese and with
toys in his car the young men follow the
supposed sex offender inside target he's
in the girls section dude he's in the
little girls and they can you know why
this is really stupid because predators
aren't obvious you know what i mean
they're not like walking around with
happy meals and toys and stuff they're
like really
deceitful
uh
really it's not like that
it's not that obvious
it sets a really good example with his
kid audience because they'll think it's
that clear to determine if someone's a
predator
like look at his car do you see toys no
okay it's good he's safe to get in the
car
look at his glovebox do you see any
happy meals okay it's safe let's get in
front him as he leaves hey why were you
taking those pictures at chuck e cheese
they claim they turned over their
evidence to the man's probation officer
we heard from viewers like this one
asking us to look into the matter people
also reached out to officers amherst
police said in a statement today these
complaints were immediately investigated
by the department's special victims unit
the publisher of the video was
identified as a 21-year-old hamburg man
the subject was interviewed and
immediately apologized for any alarm
stating the post was for entertainment
purposes only and there was no actual
sex offender depicted he's still saying
it's real after that report to the
police
yeah he's saying he said he never
scripted any he never scripted a video
in his life the police are like oh
really so where's the evidence he's like
i'm so sorry
it's all fake it's all fake i made it
all up
that's pretty good not many of these
fake pranksters of which there's a lot
actually have two men claim to be
confession to the police right
just straight up happens
it's fake
why is it not sliding okay there we go
so that's a good one life of
luxury pranks ended up getting fully
demonetized interesting
what happened
i mean obvious right
yeah i mean they weren't exactly clear i
mean in this video it's he addresses it
but he kind of just makes it seem like
youtube did it and they're not telling
him why
yeah you know why
look at the content you're making
if you don't know what's going on we've
basically been totally shut off of ads
on youtube on luxury print so don't
worry i'm sure there's an audience for
you on facebook
you can make a killer there just repost
your videos are they on facebook maybe
yeah are they do they get views there
um i haven't checked actually recently
let me check
facebook's definitely paying these guys
to repost their [ __ ] yeah
three times what youtube pays from
as you can see every single video we've
ever uploaded has either been removed or
just completely demonetized remove
remove remove remove remove remove
to monetize so basically right now to
the best of my knowledge youtube is
trying to totally kill our channel
luxury pranks so welcome to life of luck
this channel needs to pick up life of
luxury needs to pick up if you want us
to even be a possibility on the site if
not know that we're not giving up
because if i fall seven times i stand up
into youtube if this is you where you're
about dude that's [ __ ] inspiration
just making content on your site anymore
you're doing a horrible job
no they don't want you i like how this
guy thinks that he's like you know
what's going on you know making such a
big impact on youtube's bottom line
youtube if you don't want us making more
and dangerous insane fake pranks that
make like
i don't know how you're going to survive
without us
as time went on their second channel
became more like jay station's channel
with dark web possession sonic exciting
oh hell yeah let's take a look this is
my favorite genre
guys so who was the is jay station the
real original here or the like who who
ripped off who yeah
whoa the views are insane look at the
views
8 million 21 million 10 million 22
million
well j
i'm freaking scared he's the rl stein of
youtube so
he takes credit for being the original
but is he
to my knowledge he is i mean everyone
he's ever been into beef with he was
first i gotta give i gotta tip the hat
to him a little bit on that for being an
original
you know
what the freak shout out to man these
views are insane it's amazing how people
consume this stuff
they say is this as it says as recently
as three months ago is that accurate
yeah
as recently as three months ago they
made a video with eight million views it
was hiding in the closet still slamming
hmm
he did stand up eight times as promised
luxury dark and luxury light
okay
new channel for super scary stuff oh boy
spooked already so i just got back in my
room i gotta say i'm getting really
concerned about this woman i can't what
is this
this is straight up j station
but i'm gonna keep this oh my god just
in case i get woken up by a noise again
okay again good night guys
from pedo hunting to ghost hunting what
are the odds
[Music]
[Music]
i can't do it dude i'm freaking scared
it's cause you're so freaking scared
isn't it so spooked i can't watch it hey
channel that okay so luxury light is for
the angel angelic side of the psyche
right for videos like um
filling a pool with human hair
oh
no
they show earlier in the video like
they're grabbing it from like garbage
cans and
oh so it's
they're grabbing they got a pool full of
hair just from looking through people's
garbage
yeah like
at a barber shop like a dumpster behind
a haircutting place or something
yeah i guess here's them getting out of
here from behind a barber shop
okay
that's
like i know it's fake but that is beyond
[ __ ] putrid like even the insinuation
that you're swimming in people's hair at
the dumpster around a barber shop all
right guys so chester's in the dumpster
right now looking for some hair
i really don't think this is going to
work
apparently everyone has the same color
hair at this barber shop
right
yo whoa what's the print is they trying
to make a joke what's funny about this
it's so bizarre look how serious they're
about getting hair
i think they're trying to ape the
mr beast format a little bit right of
just like we did this crazy thing bro
yeah i think they just kind of the idea
of realism oh by going out the window
and they don't
dude i don't care about saying it's real
anymore
they're just
such bad actors all right hold up hold
up some guy's talking to him
oh no
the security guard at the barber shop to
protect the hair in the back
so watch this acting
dude what was going on dude what was
that what's that dude
dude i think the guy was okay with it
dude were you stealing that hair dude
there's barely any hair in there anyway
i don't know we're doing this for like
five years why can't they act a little
bit better
well they have 20 million views so the
[ __ ] per video yeah what do we know
what
okay so do they explain how they got
that much because they he only got like
a handful
uh they found like a mother load of hair
they got a u-haul here what is this
all right get there all right
i got the hair bro
[Applause]
yo what
dude where'd you get all this hair
oh you have no idea how they're just
wigs
bro this is insane is this is this real
hair did you see oh dude this is
disgusting it smells horrible all right
let's start getting the stuff in the
pool all right let's go to the pool
man these guys are still making content
so we got the pool
the latest videos like two months ago
how many views
oh it's up there let me see well there's
something in here you're actually on
them this isn't a re-upload just uh
yeah bro let's probably license stuff
all right dude i'm gonna take a dip
okay go here give me a camera
oh oh oh oh
ew oh
oh
oh oh dude all right that wasn't as good
as i thought it would be
dude let's just could we get out of here
please four million views
i think this is the worst thing i've
ever seen i mean hands down this is just
a nightmare
we gotta go inside yeah i definitely
want to take a shower bro let's get
let's get out all right let's go
okay guys thank you for watching this
that's it
he's so [ __ ] stupid jesus
i can't you guys
this should inspire you anything's
possible
you're just like oh this is gross yeah
it doesn't matter thanks for watching it
doesn't matter how dumb you are
as long as you just put [ __ ] out there
here's their facebook page oh not doing
that well
come on guys
i feel like these should be getting like
a bajillion views on facebook this seems
like prime facebook content
well luxury light
actually no worse luxury so what's their
main one luxury dark or luxury dark is
that their most very dark yeah that's
their most active one 2.3 million
oh yeah two months ago four million
views here let's watch dude people don't
keep parasites as pets we don't want to
buy this a parasite could be a great pet
a parasite as a pet one of my personal
favorites from luxury dark is buying a
friend from the dark web
well that's a tray station plastic right
sure
yeah j-station has
he bought a lot of he had clowns he
bought black santa from the dark web he
bought a gay potion from the dark web
what was the jay station one with the
black sand he goes ew if you don't get
my fried chicken yeah you want a fried
chicken there can be problems epic joke
super epic ho ho ho [ __ ] yeah
i actually like the ho ho [ __ ]
that was
guys
luxury pranks ladies and gentlemen
that was
way worse than i expected
i mean it's crazy that that uh people
like this find a lot of success on
youtube but i've seen it my whole my
whole career i mean it's why i
it's why i have a career frankly maybe i
shouldn't be too hard on them
that's a good point it's just it is it
is a little bit scary that people are so
dumb i mean frankly speaking
that's been a theme on this episode
hasn't it yeah that we're gonna have to
think of some title like uh
suffering the idiots of the world
from one idiot to another
yeah
as a set of people who don't necessarily
consider ourselves
ian you hear about these these yeezy
shoes that were sold for 1.8 million
uh zach told me about it yeah thoughts
i mean that's an expensive shoe
i have a thought why don't why don't
they still make yeezys that look like
that that's actually a cool shoe i
[ __ ] hate the easies that they make
now
this was apparently a one of one
something it was like a one-off that he
made for the grammys and it was with
nike which i guess the original
yeah all the nike yeezys are worth a lot
more
that's incredible though the previous
um
bit the previous record was 615 000
for a pair of 1985 nike air jordan first
which michael michael jordan wore
during a game
uh
and that sold for how much for 615 000
and this is almost two million yeah one
point eight million jesus
was sold via softbees
yes
it was bought by
rares which is a sneaker investment
marketplace
so chances are they're going to be going
back on sale at some point so keep an
eye ian keep keep saving and keep an eye
on rares
and did you put a bid in sotheby's for
though i didn't even know they're on
sale
what size is your foot in
like 10 and a half 11.
these are 12s
oh well
no luck maybe next time get the next one
i gotta say i love my uc slides they're
like the ugliest shoes or sandals i own
but they're so comfortable
yeah they look kind of good maybe i
should invest in some yeezy slides i
think teddy fresh is making slides
yeah huh
that's cool
working on forever i don't know it's
like
[ __ ] takes forever well that's like a
whole new realm doing
shoes yep slides are easier it's not
like a full-on shoe because it's just
sure slides are really simple
shoes are hard i feel like we need to
find a
shoe partner which we're working on
i can't talk about it though
all right are we at two hours where are
we at uh yeah approximately
should
wrap it up
so just to summarize
on the chair debacle or is everybody
okay everybody's good zach i'm buying
you a chair
that's in fact here
let me write
let me write to lina right right to his
shoe his chair buyer lena we need to buy
because i don't want to forget zach
the razor
chair
uh ab stole from us i mean it took
your damn husband stole
yeah
well thank you i'll tell lena to send it
here first
of course
would you be upset if it was delivered
to avi's house and he sat in it first
no that wouldn't bother me what about if
he was naked
yeah right
interesting that would bother me
naked
abs all over my brand new chair
well we'll make sure there's a lot of
people that pick good money for that
privilege exactly
it's crazy good money
how people think me and zack hate each
other let me just say we're besties
it's all love
it's good to say let the people know
it's all love
yes the chair wars the chair wars are
over
everybody's getting a chair and
everybody's happy
peace and love peace and love
all right guys that has been off the
rails i feel like we've been
particularly off the rails and
we've sold this show for what it is off
the [ __ ] rails
right
sure uh yeah
[Music]
i think it's fun when it's off the road
hit me with that crash with the scream
zach yeah you know what i'm talking
about
whoa
i can't hold on
we're off the rails
wow
hit us with that you know what i'm gonna
hit us with the theme song to play us
out
to play us out
to play us out
is that a bill o'reilly yeah and his uh
freak out
that was the to play us out was the
phrase that he couldn't understand right
the play is out what does that mean the
play is the words live
there's no [ __ ] words we'll do it
live [ __ ] it to play us out
we'll do it live i didn't understand why
he's confused by that it makes total
he's a [ __ ] idiot to play us out and
to bring it all full circle because we
talked about tucker carlson let's just
keep in mind that bill o'reilly was once
on top of the world untouchable the way
that tucker seems to be right now and he
has been
disappeared from the face of the earth
well he also had like crazy essay
allegations against him i buried him he
will
be surprised if the same thing happens
tucker tucked the dick carlson what
happened to sean hannity i thought he
was king dong i think his star has faded
a little bit because i'm gone trump's
gone yeah and trump were besties he had
like the direct line in exactly and and
tucker's more angry he's dialed up the
that's insanity and he's more masked off
with the white nationalist stuff oh yeah
so um white replacement theory um yeah
no i mean you know i don't think is
making me uncomfortable i don't think
people hate trump but um his
his uh his favorability i think has
actually dipped now that he's left with
republicans the fact that they don't
like losers he's a [ __ ] loser he lost
bro they
no i mean
republicans are their favorite for 2024.
i
i'll say right now i'll say right now
that i i don't think uh it's gonna
happen for him
i think they're gonna depend i think
they're gonna move forward without them
um nope i don't think that okay we'll
see
that's
well guys
this has been another wild ride
look at ab [ __ ] stunting on zach
right now with that chair
you looking at a b
a b scooting around in his chair
oh
and ian's not even in his chair
[Music]
i've lost control of this episode
oh the train is falling off the track
zach's moving out in two days
[Music]
we're all very happy for you it sounds
like
it sounds like everybody has given you a
half-hearted offer to help you move
thank you accept me
except me
maybe give you a full-hearted offer if
he could
i know i might take him up on it though
actually
well some people say they do want to
watch you guys move so you know maybe
there is an audience
right
all right
[Music]
listen i make no guarantees
in this episode
if it's gonna be entertaining
interesting funny annoying
this is it
off the [ __ ] rails
all right guys see you on friday for an
actually entertaining show
right
fridays are good hopefully we'll see
hopefully stop it dan fridays are always
good
we have a we have we have some really
good stuff planned on friday
[Music]
friday baby yeah
[ __ ]
all right i'm walking out of frame
[Music]
you